welcome to ichi live from New York
comic-con I'm Liana Galera
joined right now by the parents of
Riverdale hi guys I am so excited that
you're all here that you are all here
right now because you know what if we
didn't have the parents of Riverdale we
wouldn't have Riverdale let's put credit
where credit is due but happy comic-con
to you guys right now do we have any
first timers for New York comic-con
quite a little you how are you liking it
it's nice yeah it's nice to be home
that's fun it's festive it's always it's
great to see the fans how crazy they are
for sure it's really heartwarming
definitely season four is premiering
this week I'm so excited for to us to
all have Riverdale back into our lives
this first episode it's a little bit of
a bittersweet episode because of course
we are paying tribute to the late Luke
Perry and this episode is all about Fred
Andrews what do you want the fans to
know before they watch this episode
you're ready to cry yeah get the tissues
out yeah and and it's a really beautiful
episode that really you know sends off
our friend Andrews and our Luke
as a hero and it really pays a really
beautiful tribute Luke in real life was
so much like Fred of Andrews that it's
crazy how much it got episode parallels
everything for us traversing and it was
hard for everybody and not just the cast
the crew that knew him so well the great
thing about Luke was he didn't
differentiate between people there are
there were people that came out of the
Woodworks too that had unique stories
about him that he shared with them
so it was hard on every single person
and of course the lovely Molly Shannon
is joining you guys for this first
episode we're able to spend any time
with each other I mean except with Molly
is fitting right here Shannon was in my
brain we created a brand new person who
is lovely as hell but Shannon Dora is in
this episode Reba is able to connect
with her on set at all I was arisen yes
so no so that was nice then we just
shared her experience unsaid and she was
really happy and really really thankful
that they asked her to do that part and
I think it was really special to have
her play that part was really special
well Molly Ringwald is here I'm excited
that we're gonna be seeing more of Mary
Andrews this year one of my favorite
things about Mary was way back in season
1 when we brought her into the fold we
realized that she has some past tension
connection relationships with these
parents in Riverdale is that something
we're gonna be exploring more in season
4 I hope so I mean I think so far we're
just sort of settling in she's made the
decision to move back to Riverdale
she's grieving with with Archie because
you know the thing about green business
is not it's not linear you know it's not
just like you get over it
life goes on but there's still moments
where Archie and Mary's really miss
and I think it's really important for
people to be able to see that definitely
actually the mighty really needs a
lawyer Mary and Mary can do yeah all
kinds of law it doesn't matter probate
law right beside I mean yeah she's a
suitor she's our lady triple team I was
gonna say Marisol mark from lovebirds
two jailbirds let's talk about the lodge
family view it has a nice little retreat
like a little when you own the prison
yeah yeah a chance to work out a chance
to just read mm-hmm it's your lyonie's
experience in prison is not like
experience in prison I'm thinking y'all
she didn't guarantee no she didn't she
didn't cut any nails
well you Hermione has one of the best
wardrobes on the show and you can pull
off any look how does she look an orange
I like I love work right nappy I like a
good jumpsuit and so does her - we're
swimming
I've been imagined that Hiram is going
to be staying in jail for too long what
kind of havoc do you think he's gonna
recon season four well I I don't know if
he is you know maybe he's had time to
reflect on some choices he's made season
three left off on a pretty big
cliffhanger because we had the I was
gonna say the return but actually the
debut of Charles we're actually meeting
the real Charles not chick he's coming
in and so this is Alice and ESPYs son
how is this gonna shake up their dynamic
in season four with the introduction of
their long-lost baby it'll be
interesting to see I think we're just
starting to peel away at it a little bit
so
be fun to see what they come up with
Eddie and Charles team up to try to find
Alice and the farm so they get some good
bonding moments and there's a little bit
of you know maybe a house full of
Converse Joneses
interesting yeah well you know the FPL
is fans the phallus fans out there are
one of the most passionate fandoms I
have ever encountered and they've
actually made a really great point we've
never seen your characters kiss on
screen okay is that something that we
could finally see in season four well I
mean what would you like to see from
their dynamics moving together fans love
their connection so much and it's been
so fun to see them kind of had that slow
burn I think what's great is you're
starting to see from the stuff we've
been doing why they have heat for each
other
you know what what is it mentally that
they connect with and that's been really
fun to get into I mean oh yeah the
connection was always there and
sparkling but now you get to see a
little bit of
and as a fees like going through some
adversity you see how alice like
supports him or which encourages and
deduce it's kind of fun to see so you
think it's a healthy relationship I
would love to see our three lovely
ladies of Riverdale come together and
film a few scenes together I think that
would be fantastic we had last season
they did the kids flashback so they were
playing your characters but in flashback
I think we need an entire parent episode
thought parent we play them
flash-forward wait that's actually yes I
cannot believe that it is going to be
season four and we're just now getting a
Halloween episode
what can you cheese out there for the
fans I understand it's wanted to be very
spooky yeah
is there any chance we could see a ghost
face mask as an OMA it was very
interesting yeah I mean we did a little
homage last season that was fun and
interesting I we haven't so far seen the
mask
yeah well I want to use this as your
time to we're gonna send this part to
Roberto I want you guys to shout out
anything you would like to see for your
characters in season four and maybe we
can manifest it here at New York Comic
Con I want to see a Charlie's Angel
yeah well we've seen the hot dad's of
Riverdale so I think it's time for the
sexy ladies sexy mamas of Riverdale did
you do an episode or like three episodes
in the Caribbean oh yeah Riverdale
vacation like Love Boat what do you want
to see for Effie I would like to see him
in a bar fight with iron punched on this
show slap punched Mary go after him Oh
fisticuffs
no no no me oh yes very well
lastly what is the one thing that you
think that Riverdale fans should expect
from this fourth season is there a word
you would use to describe it what should
they know before they go in we're
getting a lot of season one vibes it's
quite grounded
the plot is a little bit slower than the
last couple seasons and so to me it
draws in people more than it gives them
more chance to to senior high school to
so there's all that stuff and parents
[Music]
everything like the first class of
everything and dealing with loss to
dealing with the loss of Fred and Luke
which I think just you know makes
everything bittersweet and the last four
words really
yeah there's one word it would be deeper
yeah yeah well thank you all so much for
sitting down to me I really appreciate
thank you all so much for watching stick
with the stream we'll be back
bye